on sean's show he has a game called
truth or dab in which guests either
answer tough sometimes embarrassing
questions or in a very hot hot wing so
i'm planning on being super truthful
rita because
because reid and i are masochistic we
thought what the hell let's give it a
try challenge accepted sean all right
well welcome to a very special daytime
edition of truth or dab the hot one
special where we give our guests two
simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last dab today though
mercifully we're using los calientes
rojo mercifully this is probably gonna
be so hot to me so it's it's tell the
truth or suffer the wrath of a pretty
spicy wing and i'm thrilled to be here
on the kelly clarkson show
with kelly clarkson
and rita wilson
in front of you you guys have three
wings that have all been doused i can
smell the heat in very hot stuff i don't
know why you're being like oh we're nice
i can smell these it's like there's a
mirage coming off of this you can see
the little we haven't even started yet
i'm so nervous sean i have a set of
deeply personal potentially awkward
questions for you okay okay i read you a
question you have a choice okay answer
it honestly or escape the truth by
eating a wing
well we'll see how truthful
kelly is here because we're going to
start with you kelly fine
name one song from a fellow voice judge
that you hope you never have to hear
again
okay now this is not because it's not a
great song it's because we ruined it by
playing it too much
i love you john legend i love all of me
but i need a minute
i need a minute i don't want to hear it
for a minute just a minute
and then i'll be fine i'll be fine i
don't want that hot wing i'm risking our
friendship because i don't want that you
go
all right rita on to you okay
what's the best lie you ever got away
with oh oh no oh no
you better eat that you ain't gonna tell
us you ain't gonna tell us
[Applause]
hey let's make some noise
is it doable
oh my mouth is watering i'm so scared it
kind of gets hotter as you start eating
there's a build on there and and you'll
see we do have some safety nets here oh
wow yeah we have great producers here at
the kelly clarkson show we have some
honey we have some lemon we have some
bread rita diving into the milk yeah
oh my god why do you swallow it it gets
really hot and it stays there and it
stays there you know what it's still
burning it's still still burning my
esophagus
i'm so glad i got my question
you know what okay the questions just
keep coming though okay it's not over
okay i know i'm so ready who was the
worst interview on your show so far
[Applause]
i cannot tell the truth because my show
just started and i don't want to piss
people off so here this way do i start
here yep okay
oh man
oh my god it is so hot you are you are
used to hot i'm not used to hot no wait
it gets hotter no way yes
you can feel it in your nostrils
oh my god okay everything is fine is
this helpful
v8
you tell me
[Applause]
yeah i want to try that oh my god
all right rita while you sit that down
let me ask you this
get it in there oh my god my mouth is on
fire you said this was
mild has an after burn
okay i'm so ready okay rita if you could
take one credit off your resume what
would it be and why
i know mine from justin to kelly
i'm contractually obligated rita
okay um
i think it might be the movie that
haunts me every christmas
oh jingle all the way
now that's right for a great classic you
have to understand i love the movie but
i don't understand my character in it
because why does my character not
understand that turbo man is her husband
like how many superheroes sound like
arnold schwarzenegger
like how dumb is my character like i
don't know i mean it's like it's amazing
at the end of the movie when she's like
he reveals himself and she goes
howard the howard
like hello that was sexy no yes
get it tom
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going